So in Exodus 32 we'll start in verse 1. When the people saw that Moses delayed to
come down from the mountain, the people gathered themselves together to Aaron and
said to him, up make us gods who shall go before us. As for this Moses the man who
brought us up out of the land of Egypt, we do not know what has become of him.
So Aaron said to them, take off the rings of gold that are in the ears of your
wives, your sons, your daughters, and bring them to me. So all the people took off the
rings of gold that were in the ears, in their ears, and brought them to Aaron. And
he received the gold from their hand and fashioned it with a graving tool and
made a golden calf. And they said, these are your gods, O Israel, who brought you up
out of the land of Egypt. When Aaron saw this, he built an altar before it. And
Aaron made a proclamation and said, tomorrow shall be a feast to the Lord.
And they rose up early the next day and offered burnt offerings and brought
peace offerings. And the people sat down to eat and drink and rose up to play. And
the Lord said to Moses, go down for your people whom you brought out of the land
of Egypt have corrupted themselves. They have turned aside quickly out of the way
that I commanded them. They have made for themselves a golden calf and have
worshiped it and sacrificed to it and said, these are your gods, O Israel,
who brought you up out of the land of Egypt. And the Lord said to Moses, I've
seen this people and behold, it is a stiff necked people. Now, therefore, let
me alone that my wrath may burn hot against them, that I may consume them in
order that I may make a great nation of you. But Moses implored the Lord,
his God, and said, Oh Lord, why does your wrath burn hot against your
people whom you've brought out of the land of Egypt with great power and with
a mighty hand? Why should the Egyptians say with evil intent did he bring them
out to kill them in the mountains and to consume them from the face of the
earth? Turn from your burning anger and relent from this disaster against
your people. Remember Abraham, Isaac and Israel, your servants to whom
you swore by your own self and said to them, I will multiply your offspring as
the stars of the heaven and all this land that I have promised I will give to
your offspring and they shall inherit it forever. And the Lord relented from
the disaster that he had spoken of bringing on his people. Then Moses
turned and went down from the mountain with the two tablets of the
testimony in his hand, tablets that were written on both sides on the front and
on the back, they were written. The tablets were the work of God and the
writing was the writing of God engraved on the tablets. When Joshua heard the
noise of the people as they shouted, he said to Moses, there is a noise of
war in the camp. But he said it is not the sound of shouting for victory or
the sound of cry of defeat, but the sound of singing that I hear. And as soon as
he came near the camp and saw the calf and the dancing, Moses's anger burned hot
and he threw the tablets out of his hands and broke them at the foot of the
mountain. And he took the calf that they had made and burned it with
fire and ground it to powder and scattered it on the water and made
the people of Israel drink it. This is the word of the Lord.
Thank you, Tom.
Good morning.
As I begin to get ready to preach today, you might notice that on the back of
some of my notes here, I have nice St. Patrick's Day children's colorings.
So if you see those, don't be alarmed. I ran out of paper right as I was
about to print off my notes last night. And you really never run out of
paper. You've always got some here. So multi purpose.
Pray with me.
Father, we come to your word today hungry for you to lead us to teach us to
guide us.
Just as Israel has come to the mountain to Mount Sinai to see who you are.
We come to you today to see more about who you are, your character and what
you reveal to us, even in the midst of Israel's sin. Lord, we pray that
you would reveal yourself to us this morning in Jesus' name. And then
alright, picture this with me. If you give a mouse a cookie, he should just
eat the cookie, right? Well, according to the 1985 bestselling children's
book, apparently he eventually is hanging a piece of artwork on the
fridge and asking for more milk and cookies. How did we get here?
Or picture this, you have two kids coloring quietly. You walk away. They
should just keep coloring quietly, right?
Well, no, when you return, there's water on the floor. There's cheese
at crumbs everywhere. Crayon has somehow made its way onto the walls
and tape is in one of their hairs. How did we get here?
You see, there's a series of explanations with these things where
you could go and you could fill in the gaps and eventually you could
see what really happened. The mouse needed milk and a straw and a nap.
And one thing led to another. The kids got hungry. They snuck into the
pantry to get cheez-its. They took it upon themselves because they didn't
want to bother you to pour a glass of water which overflowed onto the
floor. Made one of them slip. Tape was in their hands because they were
going to tape the paper that had ripped originally and so they were
trying to do that. They slipped, they put it in their hair, the tape gets
tangled, all while the other one is coloring on the wall because they
got bored, right? These things make sense, maybe, but I'm still left
wondering exactly why these things happened and maybe you can relate to
this some in your own lives. You come to a moment when you read
something or you see something and you ask yourself the question,
how did we get here?
We see Israel being led out of Egypt by a series of miracles from the
one true God. And now, days later, we see them drinking a golden calf
that has been ground up. And in order to better understand this
and how we got here, I think it's important for us to just do a quick
rewind in Exodus and walk through what has Israel seen and what's the
setting? Why are we getting to this point? How did we get here?
You see, in the first 13 chapters of Exodus, we find the story of
Israel groaning while enslaved in Egypt. And in the midst of their
groaning, God hears them, raises up Moses to go before Pharaoh
and leads Moses and his people powerfully out of Egypt via the
10 plagues and into the wilderness guiding them day by day as a
pillar of fire by night in a cloud by day. In chapter 14,
Israel is encamped at the Red Sea and trapped. They cry out to
the Lord and Moses to Moses saying it would have been
better to serve the Egyptians than die in the wilderness. But God
had other plans. He parted the waters. He led his people across on
dry ground. And at the end of that story, Israel feared the Lord.
But in chapter 15, Israel once again returns to grumbling,
because they do not have clean water to drink. They come to
Moses and they ask Moses, what shall we drink? And the Lord
once again provides a way to make the water sweet. In chapter 16,
Israel grumbles again because they don't have any food. They say
to Moses that it would have been better that we die in Egypt
where at least they had food than to starve in the wilderness.
And the Lord once again hears their grumbling. And what does
he do? He provides bread from heaven. In chapter 17, Israel
once again grumbles because they don't have water as if one
water story wasn't enough. And they say to Moses, why did you
bring us up out of Egypt to kill us and our children? And Moses
cries out to the Lord and the Lord provides a way to get water
from the rock. Later Israel arrives at the base of Mount
Sinai. And at this point in the story, the pattern seems
clear. God has established himself as the provider and
Israel as dependent on him for everything. But for Israel,
while they have surely seen miracle after miracle of God and
who has provided for them every step of the way. It seems that
they do not know who God really is. The miracles haven't come
exactly when or how they wanted. And whenever trouble has come
up, Israel's response instead of turning to the Lord has
always been grumbling. So what does God do in this moment?
His plan all along was to bring them here to the mountain. And
he meets them at Mount Sinai to reveal who he is. And this is
the setting of the rest of Exodus. In chapter 19, he
descends on the mountain and fire the whole mountain
trembled. In chapter 20, all the people of God, all the
people here, God proclaimed to them the 10 commandments and
of specific importance today and what I want to call out is
the second commandment, which I'm going to read here, which says
you shall not make for yourself a carved image or any likeness
of anything that is in the heaven above, or that is in the
earth beneath or that is in the water under the earth. You
shall not bow down to them or serve them. For I, the Lord
your God and a jealous God visiting the iniquity of the
fathers on the third on the children to the third and
fourth generations of those who hate me, but showing steadfast
love to thousands of those who love me and keep my commandments.
When God proclaims the 10 commandments, the people are
terrified. And they say to Moses, you speak for us. Don't let
God speak to us anymore. You go up and you get your
instruction from him. We'll wait right here and you can tell
us what he says. And so Moses draws near to the darkness and
there in chapters 21 through 23, the Lord gives Moses more
detailed instruction about how to worship God and how to deal
fairly with others. And in chapter 20 verse 22, the Lord
repeats himself saying, you shall not make gods of
silver to be with me, nor shall you make for yourself
gods of gold and altar of earth you shall make for me. Here
we get the second prohibition against making golden images.
In chapter 24, Moses comes back down the mountain to the
people and relays this information to the people
as we looked at last week. So at this point, they have
been prohibited from making golden images two times with a
very short period of time. After this prohibition, as we saw
last week, Moses and Aaron and the other elders go up and they
see the God of Israel. And after seeing the God of Israel,
Moses carries on up the mountain and is there for 40
days and nights and leaves Aaron in charge of settling
disputes. And that's it. Moses has gone into the
darkness. The people of Israel wait. And a day goes by and the
next a week goes by a month goes by. And the people begin that
familiar pattern we have seen up to this point. What do they
do? Their fear leads to grumbling. But the other times
in Exodus are a little bit easier to understand. They're
enslaved to the people of Israel want to be free. They're
thirsty. So they want water. They're hungry. They want food.
But now they are afraid. Moses will never return. He's been
gone for 40 days. And so where do they turn? They ask Aaron to
make them gods who will go before them. And he makes them a
golden calf. I don't know about you, but I have a little
bit of a hard time connecting the two points. It's like food,
hunger. Those go together really cleanly. But fear of the
unknown, making a golden calf. That's not exactly the place I
would go. And so with that in mind, that's our setting for
today. I want to spend a little bit of time or the rest of our
time exploring three questions. First, this passage is often
connected with the sin of idolatry, rightly so. And so we
need to look at what is idolatry? Second, we want to look at
how does God respond to Israel's idolatry? And finally, the
question I always ask our youth whenever we're meeting, where
do we see Jesus in this story? So first, what is idolatry?
According to the New City Catechism developed by the
Gospel Coalition and Tim Keller, idolatry can be defined as
trusting in created things rather than the Creator for our hope
and happiness, significance and security. When the people of
Israel ask Aaron to make gods who shall go before us, they are
committing idolatry. They rightly recognize they need someone
to go before them, but fail to recognize that there is only one
who can go before them. The Lord. We clearly see this in verse
four of our chapter today, where Aaron has fashioned the golden
calf and the people say, these are your gods, oh Israel, who
brought you up out of the land of Egypt. In saying this,
they credited the works of the one true God to a created image
of a golden calf. And that sounds ridiculous. But before you
say to me, Caleb, I haven't created or worshiped any golden
calf this week. I'm in the clear. Remember, this people
has spent their entire lives, although a short period of time
recently in Egypt. And both in Egypt and in the surrounding area
at the time, it was common practice to create these metal
carvings of quote unquote gods. Specifically images of cows and
bulls were often used to depict the footstool or pedestal
on top of which gods like the bales of the area were
depicted. When Israel starts to become worried, they're uncertain
of where to turn. They fall back on the things that they had seen
in their life, the things they had seen others turn to. And the
point I want to make is idolatry does not exist in
isolation. Rather idolatry is cultivated over long periods of
time. So that when uncertainty comes, when things don't quite go
your way, when you're not sure where to turn, idolatry is the
created thing that we have idolized becoming the ultimate
thing that we run to in that uncertainty. You see, Israel
recognized that they needed someone to go before them. But
because they had seen this created thing, they ran to that
and that became the habit that they ran to. Who are what
today are you going to worship? What habits are being formed
that will dictate where you turn? Will the God of Netflix
save you? What about the God of your money, your reputation,
or the God of your parenting style? No. Even as I say these
things out loud, those things sound ridiculous, kind of like
the golden calf. And just as the golden calf could not save
Israel, these gods will all fail. But praise God that there
is one who never fails. So second, how does God respond to
Israel's idolatry? And I want to spend a little more time here.
I know that idolatry is normally the thing that people
would go to. But I think we can learn a lot about the
character of God by looking at his response to Israel's
idolatry. Remember at this point in the story, God has
brought Israel to Mount Sinai to reveal himself to his
people. And God's response to Israel's sin can tell us a lot
about the character of God. God reveals that he is a merciful
God and a just God who will bring judgment on those who sin
against him. And we'll see this when we look through work
through the rest of the chapter. And each of these can be
seen particularly through Moses's petitions to God on
behalf of Israel. And so I want to look at his first
petition. So turn with me verse 10. We see Moses's first
petition to God.
The Lord says to Moses now therefore let me alone that my
wrath may burn hot against them and I may consume them in
order that I may make a great nation of you. But Moses
responds to the Lord and asks him to relent by appealing to
two things. First in verse 12, he says, why should the
Egyptians say with evil intent did he bring them out to
kill them in the mountains and to consume them from the
face of the earth? You see his first appeal is to God's
own reputation in the nations. If God wipes out Israel
for Israel's sin, Egypt, who had just seen God take
them out of Egypt and into the wilderness would say, ah, this
is an evil God takes people out saying he's going to he's
going to save them and then executes them all.
You see God cares about his name among the nations.
The second appeal here is in verse 13.
And he appeals to God to remember his promises to
Abraham, Isaac and Israel. In other words, his second appeal is
to God's own integrity. Is God going to keep his promises to
his people? W Ross Blackburn in his book, The God Who Makes
Himself Known points out it is noteworthy that in neither of
these cases does Moses ground his appeal in Israel herself.
He does not make light of her sin, nor does he appeal to
any special love the Lord may have for her.
Moses's petition to God is solely grounded on God's
character and is chiefly concerned with God's glory.
We're told in verse 14 that the Lord relented from this
disaster that he had spoken of bringing on the people.
So what can we learn about God's character from this
first petition?
That God is ultimately for God.
And because he is ultimately for himself and because of the
promises he has made to his people, we can trust that he
will fulfill his promises and show mercy towards his people.
He decided to relent. He did not.
Kill all of Israel and wipe them out in his anger and
praise the Lord that he does show mercy towards his people.
However, God's mercy does not erase the sin of the people.
There are still consequences to sin and those consequences is
described in this chapter are severe.
Moses comes down the mountain and what does he do? He burns
the calf with fire, grinds it into a powder and forces the
people to drink it and note that they must drink it.
I'm gonna put a pen in that one. Just remember that one
for later.
Next, he confronts Aaron who had just days earlier actually
beheld the very feet of God.
And Aaron responds like any good toddler would by saying,
they did it. They made me do it.
And not only that, he ends up lying and trying to form his
own suggestion of how the calf was created.
By saying that he threw the calf in the fire and just out
came this calf.
That doesn't seem very repentant.
Next, Moses calls those who are on the Lord's side to him
and commands the slaughter of 3000 Israelites.
It's interesting to me and I think noteworthy that
Aaron is spared.
Despite his sin against God and his failure to take ownership
of his mistake, maybe this is because Aaron was a Levite
and answered the call by Moses who when we look in verse
26, Moses stood at the gate of the camp and said,
who is on the Lord's side come to me and the sons of Levi
gathered around him.
Maybe that's why he's so concerned about the Lord.
Maybe that's why Aaron was spared.
But regardless of why the fact that Aaron was spared by God
is an act of mercy and should be encouraging to us as we
read this.
After Moses carries out his wrath on the people of Israel,
he says to them starting in verse 30, you have sinned a
great sin and now I will go up to the Lord.
Perhaps I can make atonement for your sins.
And it's interesting that he uses the word atonement.
He's suggesting or hoping that he can repair the relationship
with God between God and Israel.
And within this second petition, that's exactly what he
attempts to do.
So look with me in verse 31.
Where we see Moses's second petition to the Lord.
Verse 31 it says, so Moses returned to the Lord and said,
alas, this people have sinned a great sin.
They have made for themselves gods of gold.
But now if you will forgive their sin.
But if not, please blot me out of your book that you have
written, but the Lord said to Moses, whoever has sinned
against me, I will blot out of my book.
In this verse, Moses is offering his own life and place
within God's book as a sacrifice in his attempt to
atone for the sins of Israel.
But God denies his petition.
Why?
Because Moses was not a perfect sacrifice.
His life was not able to make atonement for the sins of
Israel because he himself had sinned against God.
And while his attempt is noble and shows that his he has
compassion for his people, it was never realistic to
his people.
It was never realistic.
Because God is a just God.
His holiness is incompatible with Israel sin and there's
only one who is perfect enough who could atone as the
perfect sacrifice.
So where is Jesus in this story?
Moses is imperfect intercession for Israel.
Is just that not perfect.
It points, however, to the need for one who would come and
would be the perfect sacrifice.
The Gospel of John chapter one verse 14.
We are told that the word became flesh and dwelt among
us and we have seen his glory glory as of the only son
from the father full of grace and truth.
I want us to think back to remember God is revealing
his character to Israel and he is revealing in this both
mercy and justice.
And here in John chapter one verse 14.
We see those same things grace and truth.
He came Jesus to be the spotless lamb who would be able
to take on the sins of the world.
Remember how Israel was made to drink the golden calf
in the garden on the night Jesus was betrayed.
He prays to the father saying father if you are willing
remove this cup from me.
Nevertheless, not my will but yours be done.
Jesus drank the cup of God's wrath in our place.
In order to do the very thing Moses could not.
He came to atone for sin and not just the sin of Israel.
But the sins of the world.
And his coming helps us make sense of how God can be both
merciful and just towards his people.
It's only through Jesus that that mercy and justice
begins to make sense because as we think back on Moses's
petition.
His petition was primarily concerned with the name and
character of who God is.
Not Israel.
Jesus who came to take on the sins of the world.
Does that to preserve the name and character of who God
is he is both merciful to his people and he will save
his people why because it is for his glory.
But he is also just and he is carrying out that
justice on Jesus.
He's both merciful and he has just.
Finally in exodus 34 verses 6 and 7 and you can turn
there with me if you want.
We get a final word from God before he renews his
covenant with Israel.
I think this final word kind of ties these concepts
together.
God passes before Moses and proclaims the Lord the
Lord a God merciful and gracious slow to anger and
abounding and steadfast love and faithfulness keeping
steadfast love for thousands for giving iniquity and
transgression and sin.
But who by no means clear the guilty visiting the
iniquity of the fathers on the children and the
children's children to the third and fourth
generations.
Within the statement we see God proclaim and reveal that
his character is both mercy and justice and praise the
Lord that we serve a God who is both.
Pray with me.
Father you are beyond our comprehension.
And your mercy toward us is so undeserving.
Lord we thank you for being a God is who is both merciful
and who is just.
We can depend on.
We thank you that you have promised.
To keep us.
So we cling to your promises Lord.
Jesus name.